the time is right now for your album
chromatic ax it is out today this very
day it's been two and a half years I've
been making this record for two and a
half years and also it must be weird
when you when you were all geared up for
some year to come out and then for it to
be delayed it must be such an odd
feeling you know it it it it it really
wasn't odd like I think the much otter
blaring thing was that we were in the
midst of a global pandemic and I think I
just went well you know this is the way
that it is and you know we don't always
get to have things go as we see them in
life but I think it's quite important to
roll with the punches you know I'm I'm
from New York my family worked really
hard when I was a kid to earn money for
me to go to a good school and my my
parents parents are Italian immigrants
and they worked really hard and I've
always had instilled in me this idea
that life can and will get very hard and
it's important to be able to roll with
the punches and and and deal with it
[Music]